[Music]
on this thursday night canada's damian
warner dominates the decathlon
and takes gold it was a dream come true
his record-smashing victory at the
olympics
a dose of inoculation confusion are they
considered fully vaccinated are they not
what happens to travelers who got a shop
that's not approved in another country
and what could be required to enter the
u.s
plus one diver and his dedicated dad for
my whole life for the most part
it's just been him and i defying the
odds from an orphanage
to the olympics
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
bara nasser good evening and thank you
for joining us we begin
with yet another incredible feat by a
canadian olympian
damian warner of london ontario has
become the first canadian ever
to win gold in the men's decathlon and
it is a
truly extraordinary achievement and it's
earned him the unofficial title
of the world's greatest athlete and
here's why to compete in the decathlon
athletes must battle through 10 grueling
track and field events separated over
two days
competitors get points based on how they
perform in each event
and warner truly dominated he shattered
the previous olympic record
with 9018 points he's just the fourth
man in history
to surpass the coveted 9000 mark
crystal gomezing has tonight's top story
on canada's newest olympic champion
and his remarkable push to the top of
the podium
in his 10th and final event in the
decathlon in hot
humid conditions damien warner looked
fresh the 31 year old donned the
leader's yellow bib
for much of the two-day competition he
set an olympic decathlon best in long
jump leaping an incredible
8.24 meters a distance that would have
been enough for a bronze medal in the
men's individual long jump
in the 110 meter hurdles he exploded out
of the block setting another
olympic best finishing in 13.46 seconds
he dominated in nearly every event and
in the last
leg of the 1500 he raced with
unparalleled determination
warner is the first canadian ever to
capture
decathlon gold his family back in london
ontario
watching every second over the event's
two grueling days
it's been a long few days not a lot of
rest but um
yeah it was it's pretty steady
throughout we're all just watching him
have fun
good thumbs up every so often and
smiling the whole time and
putting up good results in winning
warner also surpassed
9 000 event points for the first time in
his career
a personal best now also stands as an
olympic
record it's something only three others
have accomplished in the history of the
sport
it's just it's so gratifying to see him
on the big stage perform so admirably
and get the
medal he deserves the story of warner
training for tokyo and the
complex series of events is sure to
become the stuff of legend
the pandemic kept him close to home with
no u.s
training possible and no access to
western university's shuttered
facilities
his supporters created a made in canada
solution
people from the community all came
together we built this like makeshift
facility inside a hockey rink so it
couldn't be more canadian
but making a facility from scratch isn't
easy they needed to find
sand for long jump build a high jump pit
and stay
warm in a big uninsulated arena things
that was kind of
like invigorating to have everybody come
together and be
like so positive about such a kind of
negative like situation
the community effort paid off in spades
warner not only
upgraded his bronze medal from the rio
games in 2016
but he secured a place in decathlon's
storied history
crystal gamansen global news london
there was more success for canada today
in tokyo lawrence vincent lapue of troi
revere quebec won silver in the debut of
the women's 200-meter canoe sprint
and track cyclist laureanne jenae of
quebec won bronze in the women's kieran
canada is now in 14th in the overall
metal count
with 18 medals eight bronze five silver
and five gold and just a note if you're
planning to watch the women's soccer
final between canada and sweden the
kickoff time is being pushed
back because of concerns over extreme
heat the game is now set to start at 8
a.m eastern tomorrow
that is 9 p.m in tokyo
kovit 19 is overshadowing the games like
never before
tokyo's case count today it topped 5 000
the most since the pandemic began
nationwide new infections reached 15
000 for the first time and today japan
expanded its covet emergency measures
to cover more than 70 percent of the
population
the new rules include a ban on alcohol
at bars and restaurants
and the prime minister is urging people
not to travel for their summer holidays
japan has been under a state of
emergency since mid-july
efforts to contain the virus have
allowed public health measures to lift
but with that comes a surge in new daily
infections
canada's top doctor says the average
number of new cases
is now over 900 that is a spike of
54 percent over last week dr tam says
severe illness rates are declining as
people get vaccinated
but for the millions of canadians who
mixed vaccines as instructed
there could be challenges ahead for
travel abigail beeman reports on
what's being done to find a way forward
ironically i guess selfishly i
took it because i really thought it was
the thing that would get me back to
normal
fastest but because brent matheson got a
vaccine
combo astrazeneca and pfizer he can't
take the three cruises he signed up for
cruise lines along with at least one
caribbean destination
aren't accepting mixers and matchers if
nothing changes matheson is out
all the time spent planning several
thousand dollars for the cruises and up
to
seven thousand in flight credits it is
stressful i i honestly
have had sleepless nights over this he's
not alone there are at least
3.6 million canadians who mixed vaccines
plus thousands more who got the kova
shield version of astrazeneca
not currently accepted by some european
countries
it's devastating i think we finally feel
like there's this green light and
there's a glimmer of hope
and then again we're told just wait a
second it's not that simple
3.6 million doesn't even include some
quebecers but that province is already
offering a third dose to fix the problem
it will get sorted out you know it's
only sort of a matter of time
infectious diseases physician alex wong
thinks more provinces will consider a
third shot
we're fortunate enough obviously in
canada and most of
you know the rest of sort of the first
world has a relative abundance of mrna
vaccine right now
so two doses of mrna vaccine probably
are going to end up being sort of the
standard
the canadian government stresses it's
working with other jurisdictions to fix
things while canada's top doctors warn
we don't yet know the potential health
impacts of taking
three full doses it should be based on
the science and not sort of i think on
convenience factors or you know for
based on sort of a policy you know be it
other countries if somebody offered me
another pfizer i would take it
frustrating for so many people who took
the first shots available
as they were told abigail beeman global
news
ottawa turning now to the debate over
vaccine passports several countries
including france and italy
already have passport systems in place
and the idea is
gaining ground in the united states the
white house is now considering a
change to its travel restrictions as
jackson proskow explains
foreigners could soon be required to
show proof of vaccination
to gain entry into the united states
as the world opens up to americans the
u.s has so far
failed to reciprocate banning entry for
many foreign travelers and perpetually
extending the closure of its land
borders with canada and mexico we will
be ready when it is the right time to
consider reopening travel and that will
be guided as always by the science and
the public health
for the first time the white house has
hinted what the future of entry into the
u.s
might look like including a likely
requirement that all
foreign travelers be vaccinated details
about what kind of proof would be
required and which vaccines would be
accepted
still have to be decided this is
acknowledgment that there's
really one way out of this pandemic and
it's broad vaccination
by the entire world you really do need
to have
some sort of minimum standards testing
is not enough
the explosive spread of the delta
variant in the u.s has put
any plans for loosened travel
restrictions on hold for now
there are 60 thousand covid patients in
american hospitals
cdc models suggest a continued surge of
new cases
in the range of 200 thousand daily new
infections by late august
driven by lagging vaccination rates in
many states
the biggest concern is that virus that
the virus will continue to mutate and it
will
and that it could become more deadly a
vaccine requirement for visitors would
land as domestic vaccine mandates ramp
up
los angeles is the latest u.s city to
consider mandatory vaccination to access
gyms
restaurants and public buildings new
york city announced similar plans this
week
all meant to encourage vaccination at
home
as the u.s grapples with a resurging
virus within its own borders
jackson prosko global news washington
over 4 million covet 19 cases have been
reported globally in the past week
the resurgence is prompting some
countries like germany and france
to move forward with vaccine booster
shots now the decision
defies a plea from the world health
organization to hold off until at least
the end of the month
jamie morocco explains living with two
illnesses christy dickinson takes a
weekly immunosuppressant
and although she's fully vaccinated
against covet 19 her condition means
she's constantly concerned about her
level of protection
it's just an additional layer of
anxiety i think for most
immunocompromised people early research
shows the most vulnerable among the
vaccinated may see
a significant drop in antibodies sooner
than the general public
jose lafleur who has crohn's and also
takes immunosuppressants
believes a booster shot could help by
september in my case
it's like i never got vaccinated because
i won't have any protection from the
double vaccination
the canada's top doctor reaffirms there
isn't enough
data to show boosters are needed now our
focus
is as we've said in our opening remarks
getting people there first and second
though for everyone who's eligible
bioethicist kerry bowman says this is
the right move
the way to deal with this incredible
pandemic is to deal with it globally
and you know again focusing on boosters
is moving us away from
that goal still public health professor
barry pagus wants to see
some countries move forward with third
doses and they'll be getting data from
that over the next weeks to months
i think that is critically important to
informing the decision
globally about third doses first-time
mom kay niedermeyer who received vaccine
priority because her son is
immunocompromised
says while she worries about a fourth
wave she'll wait for any top-up
right now i'm more concerned about
sharing the vaccines with the rest of
the world
dickinson agrees but says it means her
health is in
others hands i don't have the immune
system to protect myself against this
disease just on myself
hoping for a more lasting solution to
this global pandemic
jamie rocker global news toronto
speculation about a federal election
coming up why at least one party leader
is concerned about a vote being called
today quebec became the sixth canadian
jurisdiction
to sign on to the federal government's
10 a day national child care program
prime minister justin trudeau made the
announcement in montreal
alongside quebec's premier francois lego
under the agreement
quebec receives 6 billion over 5 years
trudeau has been traveling across the
country in recent weeks
making campaign-style pitches for more
affordable child care and
it's all been happening as leaders of
canada's federal parties hit the road
making policy announcements
and seemingly gearing up for an expected
election
our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stevenson joins me now so mercedes
how close are we to an election being
called welfara
buckle up and get ready to ride the
pandemic election roller coaster because
things are about to kick off after
months of speculation that we've been
talking about
multiple senior sources are telling
global news the election call
is imminent and the writ is expected to
drop
sometime next week that means prime
minister justin trudeau would be taking
down his own minority government
in a bid to come back with a majority
government
but what will that self-imposed election
be about
well the prime minister was asked just
that today
it's becoming clear and obvious to all
the parties in the house of commons that
you were going to call an election
what is the ballot question going to be
mr prime minister
we continue to be focused on delivering
for canadians getting us
through this pandemic making sure that
people continue to get vaccinated
not much of an answer there on the
record pharah but behind the scenes
senior liberals say that they hope
canadians will reward the government's
pandemic performance
and be in a good mood after a second
shot and with all of this
warm southern summer weather the
election is still a risk though while
the liberals are riding high in the
pools
they will need victories in key ridings
where those winds could be
razor thin and the clock is ticking with
rising covet cases and the delta variant
spreading
the window to go to the pools is rapidly
closing
and mercedes it's clear the leader of
the conservative party has his concerns
about an election being called
yeah aaron o'toole has been struggling
to get political traction and attention
and along with the ndp he's accusing the
liberals of
unnecessarily calling an election out of
political self-interest
now is not the time for an election we
can all wait and go to the polls
when it's safe we need to focus on
health and well-being like many families
we want to get past this pandemic
but let's pull together for one more
fight let's beat kovid 19
and have an election when it's safe the
liberals insist that they are having
trouble getting key legislation passed
and note that several provinces have
safely held elections during the
pandemic
and of course as we know the results of
those elections have shown
that in a time of crisis voters
typically stick to the incumbents
vara all right mercedes you're about to
get even busier thank you mercedes
stevenson in ottawa
still ahead alberta's top doctor doubles
down on the protested plan to axe
pandemic restrictions
the dixie fire the largest wildfire in
california has completely gutted a
historic town that dates back to the
gold rush
this is greenville after flames tore
through the area
among the buildings lost an old
sheriff's office saloons and homes
firefighters struggled to drive through
the smoke as strong winds and dry brush
are fueling the flames
the u.s is currently fighting about a
hundred large active fires
about 10 percent of those are in
california
alberta's top doctor is feeling the heat
dina hanshaw is defending her decision
to end the province's pandemic response
plan she has faced
backlash from doctors groups right
across the country since last week's
announcement that alberta would be
scaling down testing and contact tracing
and
would no longer require coveted positive
people to isolate
as heather urux west explains hinshaw
insists the plan
is rooted in science
for the seventh straight day people
gathered in alberta to protest
fearing the province is ending its
pandemic response plan
far too soon we feel very strongly that
we need to continue
to do the testing to do the tracing to
do the isolating
as a bare minimum response to
to a situation that hasn't come to a
close as of
august 16th alberta is scaling back
things like testing contact tracing
and isolation requirements the plan has
prompted a lot of concern
federal health minister patty haideu
sent a letter sunday to her alberta
health counterpart
our most recent modeling for alberta
forecasts a potentially more serious
resurgence in cases in the coming weeks
and months
fueled by the highly transmissible delta
variant
given this epidemiological context i am
seeking to better understand the public
health rationale
and scientific information behind your
government's recent announcements
i feel as i said in my op-ed
very sorry that i didn't communicate in
a way that articulated the rationale
as well as the things that we're going
to continue to do to manage covet 19.
dr dina hinshaw says testing tracing and
isolation work will shift to higher risk
environments vaccine coverage she says
means the health care system is
unlikely to be overwhelmed by covet-19
even as
cases in the province begin to rise i
believe i would not be doing my job
if i kept focused on covid as
the number one risk that we face when i
don't believe it is anymore
with the advent of vaccine we have had a
laser focus on covert for the last year
to the detriment of many other processes
uh you know cancer diagnoses
wound infections um you know heart
surgeries all these types of things
and that that's had a measurable impact
still dr
suman chakrabarti says it feels too soon
to make these changes but hinshaw's
reasoning he says
is scientifically sound question is
how will the virus respond the rest of
the country
will be watching heather eurex west
global news calgary from orphan to
olympian
next the story of a u.s diver and the
unconditional devotion
of his dad
our final story tonight is more than a
journey
it's an inspiration it's about an orphan
from cambodia who dared to dream
defied all the odds and made it to the
olympics
thanks to a special bond with his
american dad
as sean o'shea reports jordan windall is
using his platform
to achieve much more than a perfect dive
for this olympic diver who says he's
afraid of heights
jordan windall is focused on making the
smallest splash possible
at 22 wendell is no stranger to olympic
qualifying
at 12 he was the youngest diver ever to
make the olympic trials
a high achievement considering how his
life started
i was adopted at 18 months from cambodia
the one thing in the world that i wanted
more than anything
was to be a dad jerry wendell adopted
jordan after his parents dropped him off
at the gates of a cambodian orphanage
i was really malnourished at the time i
was really sick we slept in like these
baskets hanging from the ceiling jerry
had just retired from the u.s navy
when the adoption service called to say
they had the perfect little boy to be
his son
the moment i laid eyes on him you know
my heart just
he was my baby for the most part it's
just been him and i
he has sacrificed more than anyone i
know 20 years ago
jerry was not a typical adoptive parent
he's a single gay man
so at the time you know gaining a family
was just super difficult jordan faced
bullying growing up in texas
because of his dad's sexual orientation
and because father and son
don't look alike they wrote a book
together the true story of a boy
sharing their story so i decided to get
a tattoo today i'm gonna get
the cambodian flag how i can be a role
model to other children
and other people in cambodia that don't
have that chance he wants
them to be as proud as he wants all of
us in america to be proud
no matter what i have them in my heart
and i have them with me
the diver competing for two countries
and for the father who made it possible
shawn o'shea global news toronto
what an incredible athlete in every way
that is global national for this
thursday
i'm farah nasser thank you so much for
spending part of your evening with us
tonight's your canada is kempenfelt bay
in barrie ontario we love seeing your
canada so please email us your pictures
at viewers at globalnational.com until
tomorrow
take care of yourselves and each other
you